en el estudio de france 24 nos acompaña
leonardo gonzález coordinador del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz
leonardo buenos días bienvenido gracias
por estar en france 24 muchas gracias
angela vamos a comenzar a conversar
sobre cómo es leonardo hacer campaña hoy
en las zonas de colombia más amenazadas
por la violencia qué es lo que ustedes
han encontrado pues es una situación
absolutamente complicada para no
solamente para los candidatos sino para
las personas que están haciendo campaña
en que le ayudan a los candidatos en
diferentes zonas como lo acabamos de ver
en saravena pero también en el choco en
nariño en zonas donde hace presencia los
diferentes grupos armados pero también
las presiones las presiones locales
donde se hay un ejercicio por parte de
grandes terratenientes que en muchos
casos tienen una expresión a favor de
los grupos armados entonces el grupo
armado responde a diferentes intereses
no solamente a la conflicto del
narcotráfico sino a intereses y
conflictividades territoriales que se
presentan en las zonas bueno y en esas
condiciones que encontrarán usted sobre
cómo se llevaron a cabo las campañas
bajo estas condiciones de seguridad tan
difíciles no solamente para candidatos
sino como usted lo dice también para
estas personas que voluntariamente
apoyan las campañas es muy difícil
especialmente por las amenazas que se
han venido presentando contra los
líderes sociales contra los firmantes
del acuerdo de paz e incluso contra las
comunidades que hacen campaña por
algunos de los candidatos más en la
anterior campaña se presentaron más de
300 hechos violatorios de tema de las de
las elecciones las anteriores elecciones
entonces eso pero no lo indicó la misma
alerta temprana de la defensoría del
pueblo el informe de seguimiento de la
defensoría del pueblo que ha venido
haciendo a este tema y no solamente por
presencia de grupos armados sino también
por compraventa y por presiones que se
están haciendo al elector entonces es es
complicado en zonas como choco en zonas
que son abandonadas por el estado que no
hay una presencia integral del estado no
solamente por parte de las fuerzas
públicas en una presencia especialmente
de empoderamiento de las comunas
entonces ha sido difícil en estas zonas
en zona pacífico en la zona de arauca en
los llanos orientales en la guajira son
en estos momentos más de 290 municipios
que según la misma alerta temprana de la
defensoría al pueblo están en riesgo en
riesgo grave en riesgo extremo por temas
electorales y eso menos de tres días de
las elecciones en primera vuelta
presidencial y ahí va mi siguiente
pregunta usted considera se puede decir
que existe libertad de voto en las zonas
más golpeadas de arauca y más allá de
eso pues hablemos de cómo será la
participación en estas zonas bajo todas
estas condiciones de violencia y
dificultad que usted nos menciona el
voto en este momento es y siempre ha
sido una lucha por la democracia y ha
sido difícil en este país que realmente
ese ejercicio de sufragio se pueda dar
de una manera libre libre espontánea y
concienzuda de las personas realmente
estén estén pensando por él por el voto
ha sido una presión
históricamente
desde hace ya muchos años en 1936
imagínate fue donde se empezó a hablar
de una de unas elecciones libres sin
presión por parte de los militares en
algún caso y en estas elecciones los
mismos militares están ejerciendo
presión el gobierno está ejerciendo
presión por algunos de los candidatos
entonces todavía falta la libertad para
que los votantes puedan ejercer el voto
este domingo leonardo en las salas de
redacción siempre decimos que no es lo
mismo el candidato que el presidente el
gran reto de los aspirantes en este
momento es convencer a la ciudadanía de
que pueden encontrar a la crisis de
violencia y de seguridad que atraviesa
colombia hacia dónde han ido orientados
los discursos de los candidatos pues de
cara a esta primera vuelta de las
elecciones
depende de los candidatos por supuesto
pero casi siempre se está en estos
momentos hablando desde otros temas y el
tema de seguridad el tema de paz se ha
hablado no sabemos realmente por qué se
ha tocado muy poco tanto incluso por la
misma prensa en donde se no se le
pregunta a los candidatos qué va a hacer
usted realmente con el tema de paz va a
implementar el acuerdo en el programa de
todos leyendo el programa en el programa
de todos hablan de la implementación del
acuerdo incluso en el programa de
cantidad todo físico por ejemplo que es
un candidato más hacia el lado de centro
democrático es pero todos hablan de la
implementación del acuerdo en el
programa de petro habla incluso de un
diálogo sin negociación con otros grupos
armados
pero pero no sea no se le ha dado la
mayor relevancia
al tema de paz y creo que es importante
empezar a discutir cómo se va a
implementar el acuerdo de paz que no se
nos ha implementado en su manera mayoría
desde el acuerdo de paz con las farc y
qué va a pasar con las autodefensas
gaitanistas qué va a pasar con el ln con
los grupos residuales que tienen algunas
relaciones especialmente con el
narcotráfico entonces todavía no se ha
no se ha ampliado este esto que está en
el programa estamos en un limbo en ese
tema y además tuvimos el último episodio
de un paro armado de lln que paralizó 11
departamentos estará el siguiente
gobierno leonardo en su opinión en
capacidad de estos vacíos de la
estrategia de seguridad que dejó y bando
que es necesario y la única forma en
estos momentos para poder avanzar en el
paro armado de la ln y el paro armado
las autodefensas gaitanistas de hace
pocas semanas realizaron varios
departamentos y dan una muestra de lo
que realmente el poder que tienen poder
local y poder territorial y la única
forma que se ha demostrado en donde se
puede avanzar en algunos territorios en
la implementación del acuerdo de paz
primero y segundo nada que llegue el
estado de una forma mucho más amplia a
todos los territorios con vidas que
lleguen con créditos para los campesinos
es decir es necesario hoy la
implementación del acuerdo de paz y un
estado mucho más amplio hacia asia estas
zonas que son marginadas bueno y el tema
que ustedes son especialistas y del cual
llevan un juicioso registro el asesinato
de líderes sociales y de firmantes de
paz cuál es la expectativa de ustedes
para este nuevo proceso y este cambio de
mando que se viene para el país pues en
estos momentos este ha sido el peor año
creemos que llevamos los cinco meses más
graves para el tema de líderes
solamente en el 2022 van 79 líderes con
la lidereza asesinada el día de ayer van
44 masacres nada comparado con en los
años 2002-2003 y a veces nos olvidamos y
creemos que estamos en la peor de las
épocas del conflicto armado colombiano y
el inicio este siglo ha sido el peor en
todos los temas pero por supuesto que
si seguimos así podemos ir a un camino
mucho peor entonces creo que es
necesario que ya el presidente que sí
que sigue tome las riendas realmente del
acuerdo de paz y empieza a implementar
de una forma el real que los penes sean
reales que punto 4 sobre el tema de
cultivos de uso ilícito realmente le
cumplan a los campesinos lo que les han
prometido el tema de tierras el tema de
seguridad creo que es necesario o si no
volveremos otra vez aún los peores años
del conflicto a retroceso toda esta
semana hemos realizado entrevistas
acerca de los flancos en cuanto a
colombia y la que le voy a preguntar
ahora ya se le dice otro de nuestros
invitados a comienzos de esta semana
vincular la posición del gobierno
nacional que va saliendo ahora frente a
los acuerdos de paz con este aumento
casi que descarado y atroz o de los
asesinatos de líderes sociales y
firmantes del acuerdo de paz con duke
llevamos solamente con duke de los 1.306
líderes asesinados con duque fueron 927
de
2.306 de los firmantes de acuerdo de paz
van 320 y en la época de duque fueron
245 al día de hoy en las masacres y es
igual en masacres van 263 de las 310
desde la firma del acuerdo de paz es
decir este ha sido un gobierno que no le
prestaba atención a la seguridad en los
territorios que no ha implementado el
acuerdo que el paok y las diferentes
programas de atención en temas de
seguridad no han dado resultado porque
piensan que la seguridad solamente por
vía militar la seguridad mucho más allá
la seguridad tiene que ver especialmente
con la garantía de los derechos humanos
y la garantía de la defensa de los
derechos humanos